A city is not a museum.
A city is really kind of
almost a living,
breathing organism.
Austin’s the greatest
city on earth.
Unfortunately, the secret is out.
Our existential challenge
is affordability issues.
The American dream of owning
a home is harder than ever.
It’s especially out of
reach for Austinites,
who are facing every
issue imaginable.
We traveled to Texas to learn
more about their housing crisis
and possible solutions.
Austin population growth has been growing at a very high clip
for almost 150 years.
What changed in the 1980s
is that many different types
of housing were limited
or even banned
to a certain extent.
Think of a land
development code
as having zoning tools.
So you look at a piece of land.
You look at the needs
of a community
and then you can figure out
what you can craft
to fit on this land
that fits within that zoning tool.
We rewrote our land
development code
and there was a big downzoning
for much of Austin.
And housing supply
didn’t keep pace.
The housing crisis has
just reached a level
where even upper, middle-
class folks are struggling
to find housing in Austin.
We saw a slow and steady
appreciation of housing prices,
really since the Great Recession.
And then in the last
couple of years,
we’ve gone from 6% to
we’re looking at 20% a year
appreciation in home prices.
So Austin was a big benefactor
of these pandemic moves.
People who are newly able
to work remotely
moved their families and
their high salaries to Austin.
These low interest rates
allowed them to buy
single-family homes,
buy property,
and that has driven up costs
for a lot of the existing
Austin residents.
We’ve got two sets of problems
in a place like Austin:
low-income people having a hard time affording housing.
And then there’s another
set of problems:
our zoning laws are
making it too expensive
to build new housing
that even
the middle class could afford.
So back in 2012,
in an effort to get ahead
of the coming wave,
the city council adopted
a plan called Imagine Austin
to recommend a new
zoning framework.
In Imagine Austin,
it calls for a new land development code
that promotes a compact
and connected city.
We had this process,
we dubbed it Code Next.
A small group of homeowners then filed suit
and unfortunately blocked that new code from being passed.
Code Next is stuck in
the courts right now;
unclear what’s going to happen.
You run into the culture
wars and NIMBYism
as soon as you try to do that.
Folks that are in these
legacy neighborhoods
that are within a few minutes
of being downtown
that are there because
they like the big yard,
they like the space
that they have.
Part of the problem,
advocates say,
are restrictive zoning codes
that have existed in
Austin for decades.
It restricts what kind of dense housing can be built where
and it gives property
owners a lot of say in
what kinds of developments
can come into their neighborhoods.
One of the most problematic
aspects of Austin’s
zoning regulations
are the minimum lot size
for a single-family home.
We have a minimum
5,700 square foot
lot size for somebody to build
a single-family home.
That is the biggest
of any of the major
cities in Texas.
So now the housing
costs have grown
where we have these
single-family zoned areas.
We’re just seeing
$1 million homes,
$2 million homes replace
those former homes
that were just torn down.
And so we’re not gaining
housing inventory,
but then we’re also watching
that median home
value of all those
neighborhoods skyrocket.
The East Cesar Chavez neighborhood is located
on the east side of Austin
and was historically
one of the most diverse
communities in the city.
But gentrification amid
the housing crisis has
pushed older residents
farther away from downtown.
In East Austin, we have
zip code 78702.
That area is now one of the
most posh areas in Austin.
So single family homes
that not that long ago
were $40,000
are now over $1 million.
Places like East Austin,
which are predominantly Black
and Hispanic neighborhoods,
have depressed land values,
which means it’s easier
for developers
to come and build there
versus in communities like
West Austin and Central Austin,
which are more
expensive to build on
and which have whiter, wealthier
homeowners who are able
to deter and delay
these new construction projects.
So where building happens
is very much influenced
by who lives in these neighborhoods
and what kind of political
power is exerted there.
The worst thing that we can do
for displacement and gentrification
of our working-class population,
especially our Black
and brown population,
is the same thing
that we’ve been doing
for the last 20 years.
We need to build housing
so all the people that are coming
because of the Tesla factory,
because of the Samsung factory
that’s going to be built,
have housing that they can buy
and are not competing
to buy the same
old little East Austin house.
If you’re building
homes in Austin,
the best and most profitable thing that you can do
is buy an old home,
tear that home down
and build a huge McMansion
on that same property.
I want that to change to
where that same lot
is going to be redeveloped
with two homes
or with three homes
or with a four-plex.
What’s really on the table is
what are called transition zones,
which are areas that are sort of
between those busy streets
and then those quiet interiors
of the neighborhoods.
And that’s where really a lot of the controversy is right now.
How big should those
transition zones be?
I’ll say my personal preference is
I’d rather just raise the bar
across the whole city.
I think that’s a simpler and
a fairer way to do it.
That’s in fact what the city
of Minneapolis did.
Citywide zoning reform
has remained elusive.
In the meantime, Austin voters
have approved multiple
bond measures
to build affordable housing,
such as a $350 million bond
in November 2022.
Honestly, we probably
need to add
a $250,000 housing bond
every two years
for the next 20 years
if we want to get a critical
mass of public housing,
of affordable,
publicly subsidized housing,
that there are enough units
where we are able to house
a lot of our working
poor and folks
that really need help.
You know, one of the things
I’m most proud about
in the time that I’ve been mayor
is that our city has taken really
big steps, big enough
to actually bring forth
real transformative
change in our city.
But if you don’t deal
with your really big challenges,
then they just get bigger.
I think it’s important
that we look at zoning,
not only as not a silver bullet,
but a double-edged sword.
Upzoning can actually do
tremendous harm to
some communities
and especially the people who are most vulnerable in the market.
And upzoning only works to
achieve our housing goals
if we’re pairing it with other
tools and collaborations.
Solutions like building
on public land
at deeply affordable rates.
I’m a firm believer in
community land trusts.
Unfortunately, many of the community-based solutions
that are truly equitable,
they’re not moving at scale.
The most affordable units
we have are the ones
we have now
and it costs us much less
to protect those
and to preserve those
than to build new units.
It’s not to say we shouldn’t
build new units.
We need to build new
affordable housing,
but we’re going to have to
disrupt the market as we do it.
I think that cities that are
smaller than Austin
that think they may be
on the same
or a similar trajectory over
the next 10, 15, 20 years
should be learning,
going to school on us.
Goodness knows we
did not do the things
10 and 20 years ago
that we should have.
I would tell other cities
that they have to prepare for
the growth that is coming.
A lot of times the growth and
the change is uncomfortable.
There is sometimes a
resentment of the newcomers,
but if you don’t build housing
for the people
that are moving to your city,
you’re going to price out
your current residents.